Wir haben hier ja schon öfter mal über das so genannte
fermi paradoxon berichtet diesem widerspruch zufolge ist es äußerst seltsam dass die menschen noch keine außerirdischen entdeckt haben dabei hätten
intelligente zivilisationen im weltall doch genügend zeit gehabt
weite teile des universums zu kolonisieren ein forschungsteam hat jetzt herausgefunden
wir wissen einfach viel zu wenig warum haben wir also noch keine aliens gefunden jetzt hier bei pixum science fiction herzlich willkommen
Der physiker in rico ferme hatte 1950 das thema auf den tisch gebracht und zwar auf einem weg zum mittagessen
als er im gespräch mit einigen seiner kollegen über ufo-sichtungen und die existenz von außerirdischen
überhaupt war am ende so heißt es soll er dann gesagt haben herr is everybody
dass wir trotz intensiver suche keinerlei spuren von außerirdischem leben finden sei einfach nur paradox fand er seitdem wundern sich
forschungsteams weltweit warum wir einfach keine spuren von
außerirdischen finden denn falls sie existieren müssten wir dann nicht über hinweise zu ihnen nur so stolpern
dem ist aber nicht so folgt daraus also die schlussfolgerung dass es keine
intelligenten außerirdischen gibt dass sie zb wie zahlreiche zivilisationen hier vor uns auf der erde und vielleicht auch wir einfach untergegangen sind
sich zb mit einem selbst verursachten
klimawandel vernichtet haben das unsere ganze suche nach ihnen von vornherein erfolglos ist und war dazu gibt es eine menge
erklärungsversuche außerirdische zivilisationen würden an großen herausforderungen scheitern das weltall zu kolonisieren oder aber
außerirdische lebewesen hätten zu viel angst sich uns zu offenbar wer sagt dann aber dass sie unbedingt neue galaxien
kolonisieren wollen vielleicht waren sie auch schon längst bei uns und die beweise dafür sind zusammen mit den dinosauriern von der erde verschwunden
und woher sollen die außerirdischen überhaupt die ressourcen haben um unzählige andere sterne zu bereisen
ein forschungsteam aus oxford hat sich diese fragen jetzt gestellt und sich eingehend mit dem fermi paradoxon
beschäftigt in ihrer arbeit argumentieren sie dass alle unsere an haben zur existenz von außerirdischen
extrem unsicher sind und wenn man diesen wissens mangel
berücksichtigt dann sei unsere erfolglose suche nach ihnen gar nicht mehr so paradox wie von fermi beschrieben gar nicht so unwahrscheinlich
sei demnach auch dass die menschen tatsächlich die einzige intelligente zivilisationen im universum sein
ihre annahme stützt das oxford forschungsteam auf der so genannten drake gleichung
dabei ging diese kurioserweise in vielen anderen argumentation als beleg dafür dass es viele andere
zivilisationen in unserem universum geben muss aufgestellt wurde sie tatsächlich um zu berechnen wie viel intelligente zivilisationen
im universum existieren könnten konkret enthält die drake gleichung viele verschiedene faktoren in diesem kontext
beispielsweise die anzahl der planeten in der habitablen zone und die chance dass dort leben entsteht so wie auch die wahrscheinlichkeit wie
intelligentes dann sein könnte doch ihr könnt es euch denken die meisten der dort befragten faktoren basieren lediglich auf
groben schätzungen da konkrete zahlen fehlen und so werden schätzwerte eingesetzt so dass die drake gleichung sehr sehr
unterschiedliche ergebnisse liefert wie kommen die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler also auf ihr ergebnis das forschungsteam nimmt keine schätzwerte in ihrer studie sondern
wahrscheinlichkeit verteilung die auf zahlen basieren die wissenschaftliche literatur verwendet werden und das ergebnis ist
eindeutig demnach sind wir mit einer wahrscheinlichkeit von
53 bis achtung
99,6 in unserer milchstraße allein und im sichtbaren universum liegt die wahrscheinlichkeit dafür bei
39 85 prozent doch die studien autorinnen und autoren machen einschränkungen beispielsweise
würde die entdeckung von leben auf einem anderen planeten die
wahrscheinlichkeit erhöhen dass sich auch anderweitig noch leben entwickeln kann also zum beispiel auf enceladus
dazu einer der beteiligten forscher an dass am berg in einem interview mit
futurezone.at
aber selbst dann gibt es durch die unsicherheit für die entstehung von komplexem leben und intelligenz immer noch eine gute chance
dass wir die einzige zivilisation in einem belebten
universum sind wenn das leben das wir anderswo finden genau wie das leben auf der erde ist und nur durch meteoriten
den himmelskörpern transportiert wurde sagt uns das gar nichts der forscher ist zudem der überzeugung dass eine kontaktaufnahme
zu außerirdischer intelligenz auf gar keinen fall unmöglich ist dafür müsste man seiner meinung nach zielgerichtet nach signalen suchen die
außerirdisches leben
unabsichtlich verschickt durch industrielle aktivitäten beispielsweise oder durch das errichten großer bauwerke
das forschungsteam aus oxford nimmt allerdings an
dass das prinzip von der entstehung von leben alles andere als einfach ist falls sie es irgendwann einmal widerlegt werden könnte müsste man von
limitierenden faktoren ausgehen die unsere kommunikation mit außerirdischem leben so schwer beziehungsweise
unmöglich machen beispielsweise weil die anderen zivilisationen in wasser gefangen sind und so praktisch stumm bleiben
das fazit der aktuellen studie der wissensstand der menschheit ist so klein dass es gar nicht überraschend ist das werk ein
außerirdisches leben sehen doch versteht mich nicht falsch das forschungsteam aus oxford meint damit auf gar keinen fall dass wir zu 100 prozent
allein im universum sind dazu noch einmal sandberg wir wissen schlichtweg nicht genug um so etwas zu behaupten
leben und intelligenz könnten überaus selten seien das einzige
was wir sicher sagen können dass beides möglich ist die unsicherheit zeigt uns dass selbst wenn leben und die intelligenz folglich sind
zivilisationen trotzdem so selten sein können dass der leere himmel
nicht überraschend ist der forscher selbst ist übrigens der persönlichen überzeugung dass es andere intelligente
lebensformen im all gibt
wenn er kein video verpassen wollt auch extra videos und livestreams nicht dann werdet mitglieder auf dem kanal und nimmt auch noch ein paar
privilegien mit außerdem unterstützt sie uns mit einem kleinen beitrag einfach auf mitglied werden hier unter diesem video
klicken und danke an alle die schon dabei sind das macht uns etwas unabhängiger von den schwankenden werbeeinnahmen hier auf youtube wenn er immer
garantiert über aktuelle videos informiert werden wollt dann endet mich bei whatsapp dann umgeht der die etwas
unzuverlässige abbog sie auf youtube und ihr verpasst kein video einfach hier draufklicken und am besten auch mein schwesterkanal kriegst um social media abonnieren
dafür hier klicken aber natürlich nicht achtung die
genau die glocke vergessen und hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken
außerirdische revolution bei der suche bis dann
bleibt dran